the ukrainian will to fight within that
initial first phase of those five days
um was exceptional
but the actual the product of that
fighting was all of the changes that we
saw within european securities we would
not have seen that um
unification
uh of effort on the european side had
the ukrainians folded in two or three
days like we suspected
the russian war machine has misfired
this is a very poorly planned operation
and very poorly executed operation
especially in that first phase but what
we're seeing now from tuesday onwards is
a regrouping a change in tactics much
more brutal tactics which is actually
how the russian way of warfare is yes
the 40 mile long convoy the forward
elements of that have now reached the uh
antonov airport which is to the
north west of kiev
it was a key objective uh in the initial
assault for russia and it means that
they're likely to put a forward deployed
base there and so they can start to
bring in logistics uh by uh
it also allows reinforcements not just
of heavy armor but also critically of
ammunition not mean that kiev is
effectively cut off and surrounded
um the
convoy thus far has not been targeted
by the ukrainian forces which tells us
that their ability to strike both from
surface to surface and also their air
force is uh quite likely heavily
depleted and they need to keep it in
reserve for prioritization
and also that the russian air defense
assets are now in place it's not too far
from russian air defense assets that
have been
amassed in belarus
due to the fact that no one
really knew what the full operation
would entail it seems highly likely that
as an operational and tactical level the
troops on the ground were not actually
told their objectives until very late
um which is significant because it means
that the soldiers were unable to prepare
so
do map studies for example to really
understand the ground to look at the
intelligence that was coming out of the
ground which
um was either not listened to or it was
very poor
so poor political military leadership
has just filtered down to the
operational tactical level and
made this very difficult huge logistics
issues
that said
russians still have mass they have now
put 80 of their forces that were
committed to the borders of ukraine into
ukraine so it could still go russia's
way they've just made it very difficult
for themselves kharkiv is actually a
quite pro-russian
um population so um the russians will
need to be careful in terms of how
indiscriminate their fire is because it
could turn even a russian population
against
the russian military
for the ukrainians the the key part of
the operation now is ammunition resupply
which is going to be very very
challenging in getting all of these
capabilities that the europeans have
pledged that's currently in poland to
the front line
and that's almost
where the ukrainian
resistance could could succeed or fail
and the key difference now between the
ukrainian and the russian forces is the
moral component
the ukrainians have fought very well and
morale is very high
and that is infectious and it is clearly
not just between the ukrainian
professional soldiers but also the
ukrainian civil society as a whole they
see this as a fight
for national survival and on the russian
side morale is very low and only going
to get lower and less significant
objectives can be
taken within the next couple of days